this is a production of Cornell
University
so I've been the leader of nua for about
10 years and it's been it's been
interesting it's been exciting so what
is nua it's a knowledge Network
essentially farmers share data through
the network providing us with feedback
and guidance of how to use that data and
better present it on the web to them the
weather data is collected every 15
minutes and tabulated in hourly and
daily summary tables we're collecting
precipitation temperature dew point
temperature humidity leaf wetness solar
radiation wind speed and wind direction
and now the company that provides the
weather instruments rain wise
incorporated has allowed people to add
two optional sensors and the most
popular shall we say our soil
temperature and soil moisture we
designate sister stations within the
network to plug in data where we have
missing data so that for instance if
we're accumulating degree days we don't
have an oops you know a week or so of
missing data and the degree day value
would be erroneous and we extrapolate
one hour gaps in our data essentially
what we're doing is we're creating with
that data decision support tools for I
p.m. and crop production so a little bit
about Noah's history it was created in
1996 by Curt pet salt who was the
vegetable IPM coordinator in the New
York State IPM program it started out as
an association with membership levels
different pay membership levels today
it's free access with land grant and
grower support to provide some funding
we initially were using sensor and
Campbell instruments sensor was bought
by a company called sensotronic those
stations became obsolete and today we've
got rain wise incorporated weather
instruments onset instruments we serve
up airport location day
as well as state climatologist Nets
through our network initially we were
going out and manually downloading the
data from computers putting that data
into a fax and faxing that information
out to growers or we were recording
messages on what was called a coda phone
for those of you who might remember
those days and then growers could dial
that number and find out what the report
du jour was but then we went to modems
and we were collecting data every day
and serving it up on a website today
we've got a few instruments that are
still connected in through file transfer
protocol or FTP we're trying to phase
that out rain wise wrote that software
for us but the majority are connected in
through the internet through an internet
interface that comes with the weather
instrument and rain wise just launched
launched a cellular data plan and has a
cellular modem instrument as well we now
have as of yesterday or the day before
375 active weather stations in the
network I think a total is probably
pushing closer to 400 but they come and
go as they're taken out for maintenance
or what have you as you can imagine
these are instruments on the ground
collecting data and we're we've got a
footprint in 20 states primarily in the
east northeast and into the Midwest we
have 10 member states plus some
individual members growers in non-member
States can now join so noah is open
access providing data in real-time query
based decision support models with
built-in bio fix or the ability of
growers to enter their own bio fix
information for for the models the
models are interactive with a user
interface this is just to give you a
snapshot of the homepage nua cornell.edu
i don't really you know this is kind of
like the sequencing slide you don't have
to read this it's okay so basically the
key is that there's a blue menu that
follows you throughout the website and
you can access weather data pests pork
station pages crop management models and
some crop pages that we have to serve up
by PM information and other information
of use to the grower as well as some
information about weather stations so if
a grower wanted to buy a weather
instrument they could and they would be
able to learn how to do that the blue
menu on the website provides the
interactive tools and a neat thing that
I've used quite a bit is up here in the
corner is a National Weather Service
little query box so you can put in your
city and state hit go and you'll go to
the National Weather Service site and
you'll be able to find out what the
forecast is for your location as of now
as many of you know the internet knows
where you are at all times ok so big
brother is watching and this map will
save to your location and center the
next time you come in on where you're
located so you know for a lot of you
Millennials and stuff that's really cool
you're excited about that for people
like me it's like ah somebody knows
where I am I don't know if I can handle
it so but anyway it's kind of cool
because then you know it basically
centers the map for you and you don't
have to move it and whatnot there is
station pages for every weather station
in the network and these provide quick
links to tools they are built on default
bio fixed dates based on historic
records that faculty have for Apple
insects grape phenology stages things
like that or typical planting dates for
onions or potatoes etc so although these
aren't interactive you can still get to
the interactive results but these are
quick links for degree days daily and
hourly summaries and then pest forecasts
quicklinks gives you lat lon elevation
tells you the station sensors the last
good download date that occurred at that
station location so this gives you a
snapshot of newaz current map I grabbed
this snippet off the website I think
again day before yesterday or yesterday
and this is zoomed in here on New York
this is the entire map here and it shows
that we're now reaching into Minnesota
we've got individuals in the plains
Nebraska Iowa Illinois and then most
recently Virginia became a member and
North Carolina so we're moving to the
south which kind of makes for a little
nail-biting of you know are the models
really useful down there so we do a lot
of discussion with the faculty that are
requesting expansion of nua to make sure
that it's going to be applicable so why
am I here well number one I contacted
Jeff and I said hey Jeff can I give a
seminar on nua everybody's been telling
me I got to get the word out you know I
gotta tell Cornell University about this
so I said okay let's do this and he said
alright so how might know a benefit
programs in soil and crop sciences well
Noah basically now is operating the
weather stations on your research farms
the Aurora station the willsboro station
and the station at chazy minor are the
stations that are on your research farms
Musgraves research farm willsboro
research farm and wh minor Institute so
I've worked with the Cornell facilities
the Cornell oh my gosh AG Experiment
Station yes Julie I'm at the new york
state AG Experiment Station you guys at
the cornell university AG Experiment
Station so I've been working with the
facilities director to get these weather
stations plugged in on the various
research farms that Cornell operates
right now we really don't have very many
tools for agronomic crops we do have an
alfalfa weevil tool that is built on a
degree day model that raker others
developed back in the day and then
obviously we've got a number of degree
days that I think might be of use to
agronomic crops so the two
main reasons that I'm here one is to
stimulate your thinking about developing
and utilizing nua to benefit agriculture
how might that happen what is your
vision contact us let us know and also
to raise awareness of what nua has to
offer so to that end I'm going to give
you a little sampling of the predictive
models or what is increasingly these are
being called tools now I always used to
call them models so if i say models or
tools you'll know that it's a
transitioning terminology and i
basically mean the same thing so we've
got phenology models for plant diseases
and insects crop management tools and
weather products again they're real time
query based decision support with built
in bio fix or an interactive user
interface where they can enter the bio
fix this is the pest forecast menu right
here off of the web and basically we've
got 14 plant disease tools 11 insect
phenology tools these are now
increasingly most of them are providing
a five-day forecast look into the future
so that a grower can prepare if they
know they're going to be at risk for a
certain disease or insect developmental
stage they can get their spray set up
and go out and apply that spray in a
timely fashion they can assess that risk
learn I p.m. info and get decision
support through these tools and again
they're interactive so this just gives
you a snippet of the great forecast
models that are available in nua most of
the models that are served up on the
website have a little utility here on
the left-hand side of the page where you
would select a disease or insect for
grapes everything is on one page so you
would select we have grape very mop
grape diseases or DM cast which is a
simulation model for grape vine downy
mildew available from this page we are
building now because we're in so many
states will have a state select the
state and then the weather station
location is selected we default to the
current date but you can go back in time
so you can select a historic date as
well obviously I needed to do that to
create this snippet by going back to
last spring when you first go on to the
page the map tab is active so if you
don't know the weather station location
you'll when you select the state here
will be the image of the map centered
and you can zoom in on that so that you
can then decide well I think this is
really the geographic region I'm
interested in you click on the icon on
the map and the name of the weather
station location plugs in there so after
you've decided you're ending date you
hit calculate and the results pop up on
the results tab and then there's more
info we might have fact sheets
information on how to use the model more
effectively that type of thing in the
more info tab so here you can see a
pretty common format that we use is a
table showing the two past days the
current date and the forecast days on
this one we actually tabulate three
diseases of grapes foam opsys powdery
mildew and black rot a little bit of
information about those models is here
what the models are doing what they're
calculating the grower can change the
phenological stage we're estimating that
tenant shoot growth is where we're at on
may 29th of last year this is based on
Concord a variety of grapes that is
grown for juice it's probably the
largest number of acreage of any variety
of grapes grown in New York but in this
region most Brewers are growing wine
grape varieties they might be growing
Chardonnay Riesling and so they can
change the phenological stage the other
thing is my colleague and I p.m. was
telling we were talking about how spring
is kind of we're all nail-biting because
spring is here and yet it's not really
April so one of the things that can
happen is you can go from 3-inch shoot
growth in grapes to 12 inch shoot growth
in grapes in a matter of three
if it's really hot and so this gives
flexibility to the model and changing
this may change the disease management
messages so these go you would scroll
down the page and then you would get to
the disease management messages for each
of the diseases in this model so that
gives you a perspective on how most of
the models work some of the crop
management tools that we have not that
many we have three primarily focused
around apples they again are assessing
risk providing decision support and
they're primarily are focused on crop
load management irrigation and freeze
risk this is the Cornell Apple
carbohydrate thinning model again
there's the utility on the left to enter
the weather station it'll have the state
selection soon the current date or the
date that of interest would be selected
the results tab will show up and the
grower would enter their green tip date
in the Hudson Valley we're already at
green tip and apples not yet in the Lake
Ontario region thankfully they would
enter their bloom date and then there's
a button here and they would click
calculate this table then builds below
this utility to provide these data
related to the tree carbohydrates status
starting from the green tip date down to
the current date that you've selected
which is the green row light blue rose
above tan rows below our building the
forecast down in time and then below
this is the carbohydrate balance of the
chart and the end user can scroll along
this and little pop-up boxes will show
up saying the date and the carbohydrate
balance so giving basically what is
being shown at that point on that graph
the take-home message for your purposes
is if the tree is in deficit
if it's in carbohydrate balanced deficit
it's going to be easier for the grower
to thin the apples off the tree so they
have to reduce their thinner rate if the
carbohydrate balance is in the pot on
the positive side on the plus side it's
going to be harder to thin the apples
off the tree has a lot of reserve
carbohydrate they're going to hang on to
all that fruit they're going to be able
to ripen that fruit so it's going to be
harder to thin and that's what this
model does it's going to tell them to
either increase the chemical thinner
rate or decrease the chemical thinner
rate this model is probably the biggest
driver in terms of end-users putting
weather stations on their farm it is
huge in terms of crop quality crop value
if you thin your crop too much you don't
have a crop if you under thin you don't
grow premium quality apples that are big
and bring a premium price this is a new
utility that was developed by art de
otoño at the Northeast Regional Climate
Center that is estimating 2-inch soil
temperature across the Northeast so
these tools that are developed by the
Climate Center provide outputs like this
they're color-coded maps that generate
this graphic and you can see here as of
two days ago the soils were warming in
the Hudson Valley but they were still
kind of cold in the Adirondacks up in
Maine and then to a certain extent along
Lake Ontario what are some of the
weather products that you might be
interested in so on the weather product
menu what I've done is I've highlighted
this because this is new as of this
month we just rewrote the degree day
calculator that art egg yellow and I had
created about I don't know 12 years ago
or so eight years ago and when we
migrated our database the programming
language wasn't compatible so we've just
kind of resurrected this and we're
really excited about it
but basically under weather data you can
get degree day tables for 11 based
temperatures and they accumulate from
january first march first april first
and May first again based on end user
requests these base temperatures usually
are borrowed from the models that we
have that we've built in nua so for
instance this 32 is for apple scab ask
us for maturity I think for c is for
cabbage maggot this bizarre one is for
great Barry moth because the research
was done in degrees centigrade and the
translation ended up being you know 47.1
for Fahrenheit we will serve up our
hourly data in tables summarized and
these are month by month tables
providing daily summary tables and then
again the degree date calculator so I'll
spend a little bit more time on this
because I think this is an area that is
growing and I've been explaining this to
our end users and they're seeing how
important this can be to document issues
that have occurred if they've
particularly got crop insurance or
something like that and they need these
data they need to be able to document
them and print them off or what have you
so it was a mild winter right yeah it
was a mild winter except for Valentine's
Day there was a significant freeze event
on Valentine's Day and in highland New
York which is in the Hudson Valley the
the data logger the weather station
recorded this event so in the hourly
data you can see how the tables are
presented and you can see each hour how
cold it got if we look at the daily
summary table for this same event you'll
see how the minimum was minus ten point
six degrees fahrenheit with fairly cold
weather each day preceding and after
that event but before that it was
actually really mild
my colleagues in the Hudson Valley have
been out cutting buds on peach and sweet
cherry and pretty much the peach crop
down there is toast most of the flower
buds were killed and the sweet cherries
the jury is still out on that so this
again it gives the grower a perspective
they can look back in time and see how
Cole did it get for how long to know
whether their crop whether particular
varieties that they know our hardy or
not hardy were damaged on the other end
of the spectrum when we talk about
severe rain events i was down giving a
talk in north carolina which again is a
new partner for noah and i said hey you
know what was a weird event that
occurred that i could go back and grab
the data and and share with the growers
and show them how they can access that
and they said my gosh we got like five
inches of rain in three days in october
and we are trying to harvest and it was
impossible and we couldn't get out to
harvest so I went and sure enough this
weather station that went in last year
Hendersonville North Carolina went to
the all weather data utility this really
should say October but I think I was
just too lazy to update it for the
purposes of that but these are the
October data this is the hourly table
for that event and you can see a third
of an inch of rain to almost a half of
an inch of rain was being logged by the
tipping bucket every hour and then when
we look at the daily summary sure enough
there's that five inches of rain I'm not
sure what might have fallen on the 30th
his September but I didn't want to try
to patch that together again these
tabulate by month so yeah that was
significant they couldn't get out to
harvest their fruit some of that fruit
starts to drop and there's a lot of crop
loss associated with that so building
capacity what can we do and what have we
been doing to try to build capacity as
of 2010 we lost all of our funding
support for Noah and it was
incidental that a lot of my colleagues
in New England wanted to join nua and so
it presented with a challenge and an
opportunity at the same time that we
could build this partnership and they
could help fund nua and sustain it into
the future our partners including the
Northeast Regional Climate Center and
rain wise incorporated we're also
absolutely essential during that
downturn so the Northeast Regional
Climate Center partners with us they
housed the new a climate database they
provide model programming into the p.i
design tools so the principal
investigator decides what they want this
tool to be and they help the programmer
decide how to program it with the data
that we have they provide data quality
control meteorological expertise and
guidance and the nice thing is that they
have a high level of interest in
agricultural applications of climate
data as many of you know they have also
helped us create automated outage
reports that go out to weather station
contacts and I have gotten a lot of
emails back initially I thought oh no
they're going to be mad we're telling
them their weather station is down but
for the most part they're really excited
about getting that report this is our
slide of partners and you know it's a
good thing it's starting to get really
crowded so we have two apple grower
associations one in Minnesota one in
North Carolina that partner with nua
Penn State Rutgers University of
Connecticut University of Massachusetts
and University of Vermont our partners
and this year New Hampshire and Virginia
Tech have joined these partners pay 1750
per year to be members of nua that's our
subscription fee rain moyes incorporated
has been a fantastic partner they have
helped even with software programming
putting leaf wetness sensors on to their
stations and developing their stations
that they actually fit the needs of our
network and this is a just the menu for
the about weather stations and a
snapshot of the
weather instrument this is a leap
wetness sensor it currently actually is
attached over here to the tipping bucket
so that it's facing north at a 45-degree
angle which it has been shown to be the
best for the Northeast so this chart is
pretty exciting and also a bit daunting
so um I became lead in 2005 we launched
the current website that I've shown you
in 2009 and the number of instruments in
this in the system has just grown
significantly over these last seven to
eight years we now have ten statewide
members and individual farms and
actually it's only five other states
because one of those states is now one
of the ten statewide members we ingest
airport data and we've put into place a
humidity and correction factor because
obviously the situation in terms of the
microclimate near an airport is quite
different from an agricultural field so
we have a relative humidity correction
factor and we also have a leaf wetness
estimate in place for those stations and
we're partnering with the state
climatologist in New Jersey for their
data that's this green bar here so
pretty exciting in terms of growth in
the number of weather stations over the
last seven to eight years our farmers
and multipliers again we have individual
farms in Illinois Iowa Maryland Nebraska
and Wisconsin Soil and Water
Conservation districts have written
grants to fund small meza nets we have a
measure net funded by them in seneca
county in the wine wine grape growing
region county and regional extension
programs have partnered with us Suffolk
County on Long Island probably most
notable they have about 20 or more
weather stations in their network again
primarily on vineyards but also on apple
farms and in vegetable potato fields
down there we have a couple of
Arboretum's and
wilderness areas obviously the airport
locations and state climatologist nets
so we're essentially crowdsourcing our
data and pulling it in the priorities of
our stakeholders we pay pretty close
attention to and obviously sustainable
funding for most of us we know how
crucial that is we'd like to rebuild our
website it's going on seven years old
now and it would be nice for it to be
responsive so whatever size your screen
was or your device was it would adjust
for that we'd love to have more weather
station locations and one way to do that
very quickly would be to use the
national digital forecast database of
gridded data and serve up virtual
station locations our end users would
like apps that reside on their phone
that can interface with some of our data
alerts and alarms for frost heat events
things like that and they'd also like
for us to be able to cash their bio fix
data they want more models and tools
station maintenance and troubleshooting
has been a big emphasis of mine in the
last year and a half because of a funded
project and then I'm here to promote
awareness because so many of them have
been saying Julie you've got to tell the
story you've got to get out and tell the
story about Noah so in terms of research
and development on weather data we
developed the leaf wetness estimator
essentially the simplest and least prone
to errors on the negative or positive
side was using an hour with relative
humidity above ninety percent as well as
an 80-hour that would be raining
obviously Arctic I tano has written and
done research on data quality control
for precipitation and when he finds that
a tipping bucket is either over recorded
or under recorded rain as based on what
the gridded data is saying around that
instrument he will send an email out to
them saying hey you know we think
there's something wrong with your
tipping bucket rain gauge again we'd
like to build these virtual stations
and if we do we can compare back and
forth between the on-the-ground data and
the virtual data a really nice fertile
ground of research would be would be
developed and I heard from Abby seaman
just on yesterday or the day before that
she and our day I tano are going to be
looking at that soil temperature
estimate map and comparing that to
sensors actually placed in different
soil types across New York so they can
see whether there's an impact of soil
type on that estimate product
development we've been looking at an e
nua email alert we beta tested this with
apples in 2011 and it's been running for
three years now with grape growers they
really like this and we'd like to
develop this into a subscription-based
product essentially for any location
they choose they can get the email at a
time of their choosing and it gives them
the results of the models basically in
an email format they don't have to go
into the website and click and click to
get the information we've got that
degree day calculator that basically you
put the start date in the end date and
it will give you the degree day
accumulation for that range of dates for
that particular location we wrote a
grant recently to develop a cash for end
user inputs first trap catch dates green
tip dates blossom dates things like that
but unfortunately a it wasn't funded so
that's going to remain on the drawing
board we also had this in a grant but
this also we did not get that grant but
art dig I tano and the climate smart
farming group are moving forward on this
piece so that's exciting and we are
still on the drawing board on a
responsive web design we are currently
upping the vegetable and apple insect
tools all the vegetable tools with the
five-day forecast data in the apple fire
blight tool we're incorporating an
epithet 'ok infection potential from a
third-party software called mary blight
art agnello has written a San Jose scale
model for apples that should go in to be
implemented this year I was doing a
workshop with apple growers and we were
looking at the Apple irrigation model
and it became clear that we've got some
work to do on that model based on some
input from that workshop and we're
always open to end-user suggestions for
improvements and over the last six
months we've created a list a wish list
of over 40 different models that are out
there in the literature and the
scientific literature that that we could
incorporate into this system so what's
the impact Noah is transforming weather
information and knowledge into tools
farmers are being able to share
resources for weather data collection
analysis distribution archiving through
integration of all these networks via
cloud computing we're pushing forecasts
out five days in advance so big deal
what's the impact before we even launch
this website before we even grew to
where we are today we did a survey in
2007 and we asked growers in New York
that we're using nua and these were
Apple great onion and potato growers
primarily whether nua using nua tools
reduced sprays improved spray timing
alerted of pest risk or enhanced I p.m.
and all of them virtually all of them
agreed or strongly agreed sometimes if
it's a bad year for diseases you won't
get that reduced spray because if it's
rainy and wet all season long you're
going to be chasing that disease all
season long these same growers reported
on average that they could save nineteen
thousand fifteen five hundred dollars
per year in spray costs and that was
2007 costs and save 264,000 per year in
crop loss again these are high value
horticultural crops ninety-nine percent
of end users of knew at that time would
recommend nua use to farmers and I think
that underlie
why this has been so popular and why it
has grown so much in recent years we now
have over two million pageviews per year
in nua some anecdotes I use the newest
site almost every day early in the
season the orchard was largely scab free
for the first time in several years the
manager depended heavily on Noah and
could see differences between their
on-site station and the one they have
been using to New Jersey growers of
apples last year had the best thinning
results ever using our tool so the
outcomes are better I p.m. reduced
pesticide use improved environmental
protection better crop management
improved crop quality improved yield and
definitely enhanced decision support so
in the future we've got some new
partners in some new directions to
consider we've just recently embarked on
a partnership with enviro weather which
is a similar program based at Michigan
State University and I've got a call in
to talk this up and see how we can move
forward to collaborate we have models
they want and may have models we want
and could really benefit from we've been
embarking on conversations with two
other state climatologist nets North
Carolina's econet and Delaware's dios i
probably killed the pronunciation of
that but deos a new york state mesonet
is going in some of you may be aware of
this 125 weather stations are going in
across New York funded with FEMA dollars
in response to Hurricane sandy tropical
storm irene and i think lee so we are
also discussing with the Mesonet on how
we can partner in the future the climate
smart farming group part of the Cornell
Institute for climate change in
agriculture is another area that's ripe
for collaboration and we'll be
partnering with them and discussing how
to how to move forward and we've also
been discussing how we
can partner with a grade are at the
University of Maine again our
stakeholder objectives we keep these
closely in mind I've talked about pretty
much all of these we've got a new a data
product for third-party software called
rim pro so we just launched that this
month so that may bring in some revenue
for that product and i would love to
create a developer sandbox so that
developers could go in on the web and
plug in their messages dates when those
messages should occur based temperatures
key risk windows you know length of
wetness that type of stuff and that
model would just essentially auto
generate you'd be able to validate it in
research mode make sure it was working
and then potentially implemented
wouldn't that be nice so the challenges
and opportunities going forward funding
funding funding obviously is big we know
that Cooperative Extension and
land-grant universities are losing
funding across the u.s. and that's why
our yearly fees have gone down down down
we've tried to keep those as low as we
can State Climatologist nets are in the
same boat in terms of funding and I'm
working with them to figure out how on
our website we can attribute that data
to that specific state mesonet and I've
got like two or three really good ideas
going forward that I think may work
we're going to have to figure out how do
we blend with existing systems like ms
us and viral weather what is the
geographic reach of our models and and
how do we validate that it would be
really great to have a model for leaf
wetness leaf wetness sensors stink
they're the bane of plant pathologists
across the nation we can't stand them we
need a really good algorithm four leaf
wetness and there are scientists across
the US and in Canada
have been working on this for for some
time we'd like to obviously utilize the
national digital forecast database and
real-time mesoscale analysis data to do
a better job with precipitation humidity
and leaf wetness in those virtual
locations obviously data quality control
is always a challenge and very important
and we want that website upgrade and
responsive web design the New York State
IPM program is looking to staff a nua
coordinator full-time if we can get the
money to underwrite that position and we
would love to have a programmer also in
the New York State IPM program to help
us build these various tools so
basically nua is access to IPM decision
support providing for the sustainable
management of pests using methods that
minimize environmental health and
economic risks we use plant disease
epidemiology insect phenology plant
phenology and crop management to
generate these phenology models and
forecasts we've got 40 plus tools on our
wish list we want more station locations
better end-user cash and alarms better
quality control and support and that
developer sandbox would be pretty pretty
cool I think we are doing a really good
job in fruits particularly tree fruit
and grape in New York and across the
Northeast we're doing a pretty good job
in vegetables for onions and potatoes
we've got some sweet corn products
cabbage maggot product we've just put a
grant in to look at insect phenology
models and Christmas trees that could
spill over and help the nursery trade in
New York and across the area that nua
reaches into but we could do a lot
better job in field crops and livestock
could we do anything with that Don ruts
professor of veterinary entomology when
he was director of the IPM program said
absolutely Julie of course and I expect
that you're going to do that
sonu I again in this open access
real-time query based decision support
with built-in bio fixes and an
interactive user friendly interface and
with that I'll end and thank you very
much for your attention today and open
up for any questions you might have this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu